sometimes there are certain things that
you have rocketing around inside your
brain that should stay there chris and
i think the eagles would have been
better off if nick ciriani hadn't
decided
to be so candid about playing rock paper
scissors with
prospects but it's given us something to
talk about today and it's
helped inspire the draft we're going to
have in about a half hour so i guess
thanks for that
thank you yeah no no doubt and listen
look these coaches are
are looking for anything to dissect
these players just get a little extra
look into a player as a whole what he
brings to it
but i will say with some of this stuff
at times too like
they can go over it goes over you know
over the top a little bit
you know it just where they're gonna
like
for instance if i was in that situation
first off i'd probably be
at back if i put myself in that time i'd
be like wait this is silly is he
serious and i'd also be afraid to
disrespect the coach because i respect
my elders and all that so now what are
they going to hold it against me because
i was nice and i was trying to be polite
and i didn't really know the guy so i
was like afraid to just
totally crap on them and dominate them
in a game and tell them hey that's why
you're a coach and i'm an athlete and
shut the hell up
right that's that's so you're not gonna
get a true look out of all that stuff
that way
you know that's where i would fight back
against that and that's where coaches
are just quirky sometimes
they'll evaluate you on the dumbest
stuff ever you know i had a coach of
value maybe once like on cornhole
and i want to be like are you serious
like you're you're going to make a
judgment on cornhole
but yet i'm out here in the driveway
knocking down threes and crossing over
people
and you're not going to make any
judgment off of that like that
coaches are stupid that way sometimes
they really are
it it's i don't get it like it it's but
but there are looking for any angle to
evaluate these players more and more
two things first of all yeah as to your
concession that you respect your elders
as jerry jones once said in a far
different context that's news to me
because i don't get a whole lot of
respect from you
secondly what's the template that's the
thing like what are you looking for when
you say to a guy
we're gonna play rock paper scissors are
you looking for that demeanor is like
all right let's go let's get yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like all right
right right oh compete compete yes let's
do it
or like is it is it
you like ah come on i mean i'm
competitive about the things that matter
yeah
a stupid game of rock paper scissors are
you going to get your juices flowing
over that so i don't know what the
answer key is
that's what always drives me nuts about
these off the wall questions
what's the right answer yeah what's the
wrong answer is it how you deliver the
answer
and again how do you pierce through and
this is what scouts are always looking
to do and coaches are always looking to
do
pierce through the pre-packaged bs that
the prospect has been
told to offer up when it's time
to answer these questions so you want to
get a glimpse into the real guy i just
don't know
what the words chosen by that guy
actually mean when it's time to decide
whether or not
that's the guy you want to draft or the
guy you don't want to draft
no i know and you know also that's like
that's the job to me like you know of
the area scout right the guy who's
in charge of the southeast or the
southeastern conference
he should have that type of information
already available to the team
you know that to go hey i've talked to
the strength coach down there his
position coach down there
you know i know a few other people that
were friends with him on the football
team they say
he is i mean he's the competitor of
competitors
you know he'll he'll take on anybody and
anything you you should have a lot of
that information there
already um but again it is
it is a very limited time you get to see
these guys
and you know coaches are quirky they're
trying to find anything they can to just
try to
find a little bit of an advanced signal
of why they like one guy over another
guy
and here's the other challenge too what
are you looking
for by way of a personality do you want
someone who's gonna fall in line and be
a robot
because coaches typically want that do
you want someone who's gonna be a free
thinker
someone who's gonna maybe push back
somebody who's gonna ask tough questions
make your job a little bit harder
because instead of having people who
just blindly follow orders
you're gonna get that is this really
what we should be doing
and the other side of it too chris when
i would pick a jury before a trial and
there's only so much
ability that you have to shape the
contours of a jury but one of the real
questions is
how do these different people
combine to create their own
entity and i think as a football coach
and as a general manager you
always have to be thinking of that yeah
we need a certain number of followers
but we also need to have some leaders
and these need to be leaders that we
feel good about
and we need to trust that they'll be
able to lead the other guys
who were picking because we think their
personality suggests they're going to go
along
with whatever influences they get from
the guys in the locker room with a
strong personality
you can't have 53 leaders in the locker
room
you got to have some guys yeah we're
going to lead and a lot of guys who are
going to follow
the leadership of the guys you trust to
lead so with each prospect i think
there's a different standard as to what
you're looking for i i would agree with
that
yes i would you know i mean you want
leaders at every position but you're
right there's a different standard for
a quarterback leader you know a
linebacker leader
uh an offensive lineman guy whatever it
is there is there's
listen there's a lot of moving parts to
evaluating these guys
there's no doubt about that and you know
two
okay i mean when when does it go too far
when do you worry i mean just to throw
that in there too like listen i was a
psycho that
in college my friends will tell you i
was the king of madden on xbox and if i
lost the game or was losing
i mean i was the guy that was gonna bash
my head against the controller and punch
the wall and do all that
i don't know is that a good thing a bad
thing i don't know i mean or
maybe i was a psycho what maybe i'm
gonna be a psycho and a mental mess
after i throw an interception because
i'm super competitive like that too
there's just so many different ways and
avenues this whole conversation could go
and
to me that's where coaches over analyze
with a lot of this stuff
that's that's what i was going to say
there's a there's a fear that all that
time and effort you have before the
draft you
spend it doing things checking boxes
creating reports
and ultimately ultimately covering your
butt
i think so much of what happens is cya
from the standpoint of
here's the concern here's why we didn't
draft a guy here's why you know if we
pass on a guy who ends up becoming a
superstar well why'd you pass on him
because you're going to get the tough
question
from ownership at some point why'd you
pa why'd all these teams pass on lamar
jackson in 2018 i remember jay glazer
reported at some point
during jackson's mvp season of 2019 that
general managers were going back and
asking tough questions
of their scouts what the hell why did we
miss on this guy
you you want to have yourself protected
so you can justify the guys you picked
and you can justify the guys you didn't
pick and sometimes i think
it's too much hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports